I'm not going to spend a lot of time on  a on this very powerful erection yes but  Herschel Walker flanked last night on  Fox news by Senator Lindsey Graham and  Senator Ted Cruz  said that what's happening in Georgia  this erection is about the people  well first of all this election is more  than Herschel Walker this erection is  about the people  want to hear it one more time  well first of all this election is more  than Herschel Walker this direction is  about the people yeah Ted Cruz visibly  moving his eyes and then trying to play  it cool listen I don't really have much  else to say about this for a guy who  impregnated so many women and then urged  them to get abortions this is quite the  Freudian slip vote Raphael Warnock on  December 6th